Hi everyone.
Thank you for coming.
I hope you've enjoyed the conference so far as
much as I have.
And one of the things whenever I come to a conference like
this, is I'm just always amazed at the sheer
amount of organization that is needed to put it
together. If you think about even just the
very basic things like the chairs in this
room, or the microphone into which I'm speaking
now, these
things are always very complicated, both logistically
and also technologically.
And whenever I get thinking about this, I always think
about how at some point there was a
first
of these things.
There was a first microphone, maybe prototypically
there was a first chair, but humans have always been sitting
down. And at some point
that was made
by a person
who sat in a room, maybe a mad scientist
or someone with some resources,
and they discovered something and they made it.
And then what happened over time was we got
very good at making those things.
To fit particular profiles.
These chairs here, for example,
they're not particularly ornate, they're not necessarily
particularly interesting even, but they're easy to stack,
they're probably relatively comfortable, and crucially
they match the color scheme and the price.
This happens with all things that go from
being artisanal, made in
some regular way by some person
very carefully
to what we would now term as industrialization.
And one of the great things about industrialization
is that it means that you can make things
and then map them to these criteria that I mentioned
earlier. The
reason why I bring this up is, I'm sure you've all
noticed,
that AI is really beginning to undergo an industrialization.
For a long time, models that were made
were really kind of made based on gut feeling
and some clever guy that you knew who
had an idea about how to do this.
And the applications were also not particularly
useful.
I think it was Faraday who said when electricity was
discovered, what use is a new baby?
Sometimes when you create these things, it's not clear how
you will use them, you just hope that there
will be some use for them.
And I think for a long time AI was in a similar
place. Right, all of these things were coming
out, but ultimately all you could really do
was interact with a chatbot.
And now if you look where we are in 2025
going into 2026,
it should be clear that there are lots of very
useful and economically viable uses
of AI
that people want to deploy inside businesses
and they want to benefit from
what AI can give them.
I also think very crucially, if you look at the
language that companies are using and the
industry is using to talk about AI
we hear Nvidia talking about AI
for the factory age.
You're gonna hear me today talking about a model factory.
All of these companies are really hinting at how
much AI is scaling up.
One thing we're really bad at doing as
an industry
is talking about how we build models.
Occasionally a model might come out, and you'll
get some nice new model card and maybe
some eval scores,
maybe if you're lucky, like with a deep seek, you'll get
a paper,
but that doesn't really begin to cover the
real technicalities and difficulties
behind actually building foundation models
at scale.
As an industry, we're really bad at this, and
I think it comes from a place of fear about giving
away some secret source.
We don't really talk about, you know, the tricks
or the things that we have to do, or even
the battles that we fought to build models
that actually matter.
And quite frankly, I think this is quite ridiculous,
because you could, the ideas are very cheap.
It's execution that matters.
And I wanna be very clear, I'm here to talk today about poolside
and how we build models in our model factory.
But I guarantee you that every company that
is at the frontier has a version of
this. I can only speak to ours,
because I've only worked here and I only know about
this, but I'm pretty sure that your OpenAI's,
your anthropics, your XAIs, all of these companies
have a similar thing.
This is what you need to be at the frontier.
This is what we have used to get to the frontier,
and I want to spend some time today talking to you about how
this works and how it will enable us to continue
improving
our models going forward into the future.
Now, I think it's worth starting
from the beginning.
So those of you who have trained models in
the past will be familiar with a
workflow that looks something like this.
So to give you an analogy, let's imagine
that we wanted to build a model that was
really good at imitating Shakespeare.
And we're gonna do it in this old fashioned way.
What we would first do is we would first decide on
some data set.
That might be
Shakespeare's sonnets, that might be English language,
that might be code even in some senses.
But it could equally be something that I've gotten some from
guy, some guy down the pub.
Right, there's not really any way here to
interrogate what our data set should be.
We just choose one and hope that it turns out to be
a good data set,
again based on our intuitions.
Once we have that data set,
we're gonna feed it into what's called pre-training,
which is this process of, you know, doing
next token prediction, computing the loss.
Believe me, I could go into that for a long time, but I won't.
And again, there are lots of decisions that you need
to make here,
but in this model we simply cannot
interrogate in any scientific way.
Right? I might have some intuitions about the architecture
that I need to make a good model.
My friends might have some intuitions about what
makes a good model from an architectural perspective.
But there's no real way of discovering
how we could have done better.
And equally, once we've finally done
this pre-training, and believe me, there's a lot that goes into
it, we get into the stage at the end called
fine tuning.
And this is the bit where we take this,
this person or this model that we've taught to write
Shakespeare,
and we give them detailed instructions of what
it is they should do.
So you can imagine, much like a child that goes through
primary education.
They get to the end of their life,
and then you give them some, oh sorry, they get to the end of
their school life, and then you give them some
specific training. So maybe they want to be a doctor,
maybe they want to be a computer scientist, whatever it
is, you give them some particular training.
And again, what's really crucial here is that
this is just one model out of an infinite
number that we could have trained.
Right, at any point along here we could have
made a different decision
that would have led to a different and maybe
better model.
But with this, you have no way of
knowing
how your model could have been better or what
you could have done to make it better.
We have no insight into how good
the data set was at actually making our
model good at Shakespeare.
Right, maybe the trick to getting a model that
writes good sonnets is to expose it to
French or German or Greek.
We don't have any insight into that.
Equally for the sum number of parameters
or for some fine tuning strategy.
We're just stuck assuming that the model that
we have is good.
Even if we trained multiple models, maybe
we had multiple physical hypotheses,
and we think, oh you know what, I'm just gonna sit there and
repeat this process vertically many times.
That is a really heavy engineering
task.
You would need a huge team to do this, because
there's so many things that you need to get this
right, that there's just in this
form, there's a huge amount of manual intervention
that is needed.
Pre-training, for example, is a notoriously
buggy process.
Nodes die, you need to make sure that your training
is stable and doesn't restart.
And doing all of that manually is
impossible.
You would need a huge team to
do this in some way that actually
enabled you to be productive.
And I really want to narrow in on this point, which
is that there is a very large
gap,
both in terms of the headcount that you need
and the talent of your employees and
quite frankly the systems that you've built.
To go between training one model to
training many models at an industrial
scale. And again this kind of
comes back to what I was saying about the chair earlier on.
It's very easy for one person to make a chair,
one skilled carpenter can probably knock out a
chair very quickly.
But making the number of chairs that are in this room,
let alone at this conference,
is a much bigger challenge.
And crucially, doing it in the old fashioned
artisanal way is very slow.
Right, you need to sit down, you need to have
ideas, you need to run this very buggy
training process.
That's really tough,
and it means that it's very easy to fall behind
where everyone else is.
Because there's always someone who's gonna be smarter than you,
more resourced than you.
And you can't scale that way if you want to compete
with these much larger companies in the way that we
do. So I've
said a lot about how you can take,
or how you want to improve
a model that you've trained.
But one of the good things is to have some objective
way to do this.
So this is quite common in the industry now, whenever a
model card comes out, you'll see evaluation scores
across various benchmarks.
And actually it turns out that it's really useful
to be able to deploy these evaluations
almost anywhere.
So here you'll see that we have this on
the pre-training
block.
But actually, this is something that makes sense to
have also at the end
or at the beginning, in fact throughout training.
One of the reasons why this is really useful
is because as you go over your data
set, your model could get worse.
Right, it could be the case that your model picks up
some bad information, right, maybe it reads some
disinformation from Reddit or
maybe it reads some English document from
before modern English.
These are all things that can make your model worse.
And it turns out that having some way to automatically
evaluate how your model gets
better over time
really is useful.
Now I want to be really clear about this as well,
because it's an important point.
Evaluations are not everything.
The way that I like to think about this is if you have a child,
as someone who has perhaps not much intelligence,
standardized testing actually will tell you the difference
between what is a smart child and what is perhaps not a smart child.
Because actually, the sum of the things that they could know
is probably relatively small.
By contrast, by the time you get someone who is very
highly educated,
the model that is good for you, or the person
that is good for you in your business.
Might not necessarily be separable from someone who
isn't good for your business based on standardized
testing, right, it's more of how friendly
they are, how much you like to talk to them, how
helpful they are.
These are all very er soft
things, they're very intuitive, I think, to people.
And so even though we have this evaluations
thing here, I want to stress that at Poolside
we do a huge amount of
manual vibe checking.
So it's a companywide effort. If
there are salespeople who want to try
a new model,
they're more than welcome to at any stage of training.
And our engineers do the same thing, we really interrogate
our models as often as we possibly can
to make sure that they are going in the right direction.
One real crucial advantage of this
is that often your models are really
bad at one thing in a particular area.
So for example, me personally, I can't speak French.
If you ask me a question in French, it would be clear that I
don't know it. Now that might be a flaw
of me as a person, maybe not,
but models fail in a similar way.
Right, often they have gaps in their knowledge that are very
systemic.
And it can be useful to interrogate them personally
to see, OK, what is the gap in their knowledge,
how can I improve this overall thing?
Now one of the things about evaluations
is that you need a way to actually run your model.
So we've just added another box to our diagram,
which is an inference service.
Now, inference is a
very interesting area, we could talk about it
for a very long time.
But something I want to point out is that it
is not necessarily clear straight
away how you would co-locate training
and inference in the same
world, right?
And this actually is primarily a scalability
argument. You could use the
same nodes, the same physical nodes for
training and inference.
But actually in practice,
that means you can't scale them independently. Right,
you would have to scale up your training world to
also scale up your inference world.
And because we want to run this inference, right,
we want to interact with our models during training,
we need a quick way of transferring the
weights that we've produced
between training and inference
without blocking either of them.
Right, if we had to stop our training every time to
offload weights and then deploy them on evaluations,
that's going to cost us a huge amount of time.
And the whole purpose of this is to enable us to
build better models faster.
And so one of the lines on this graph that's actually
been very crucial for us is having a
way to move weights between
our pre-training and our inference.
And this makes it very easy to look at how
your model's evolving,
how it's getting better, all of these things.
We'll come onto this later, but I think it's an important point
to mention here.
One of the very
good ways to choose between different model architectures,
if all else is the same,
is how capable they are at doing
quick inference.
So we have some models that on evals
or when we're doing our preliminary ablations
actually perform very similarly to each other.
And a good way to choose between them is to see, OK,
which one has better inference in practice.
And of course, you know, we optimize, right, we take these
models once we've picked one and we do
lots of tweaks to make it as quick as it can be.
But making sure there are no fundamental reasons
why your model is slow
actually is a really good thing to do before you
invest in a huge training run.
Now, once we have this.
You can make decisions about trade-offs.
So I've mentioned this already in the context of
making sure that your model has quick inference,
but actually there are lots of other places where
this is useful.
Normally when you're building a model,
in your head you have a parameter budget
in mind.
Let's say, I don't know, you want to build an 80 billion
parameter dense model or a 500
billion MOE model.
These are parameters that you can spend in many
different places.
Right, you could make your embeddings bigger, you
could have more parameters allocated to
your MLPs. These are all parameters
that you can spend,
and when you have these insights, suddenly
you can be very informed about
what the model actually should
be like
and balance it against all of your requirements as a
business. Now,
I want to give you an example
of where this sort of thinking can really
help you. So historically as a
company, Poolside has operated under the
thesis
that if you make models that are good at writing
code, they're also generally
capable.
Now this was a little bit of an out there thesis when we
founded the company in 2023,
but it's gradually become more mainstream. Right,
companies have started releasing coding products
for their models,
and I think they're all seeing a similar uplift that
we've seen.
When you have a model that is good at writing code,
it turns out those skills really
transfer over to other tasks.
Now I want to be clear here, what I'm gonna talk about in a second
is not just limited to coding,
but coding is a good place to start.
So I think
personally
that the way that pre-training works for
specific skill acquisition
is nonsense.
Think about it like this, if you wanted to learn
to write C++,
you would never read every single C++
program that had ever been written.
It would be nonsense, you would never learn to write code,
because you never actually do it, you're just acquiring
information. And it turns out that the same
is really true for
foundation model building.
So one of the things that we do at poolside
is we enable our model during
training and also at various points post
training to interact
with a coding environment.
So you can think of this like a docker container
or some virtual environment of some kind.
And you give it tasks to solve.
Now these tasks can really vary in difficulty.
They can go from add a doc string to
this Python function to implement
this entire epic in this repository.
The whole point is that you should be able to stack
these in a way that enables the model to learn
better, right, you, you know, you wouldn't give a
kid a PhD level math problem,
you would give them a question about addition.
The same is true of models when you're trying to get
particular capabilities.
Something else to note is that although this diagram
has this going into the pre-training box,
this whole thing can be slid along an axis,
pretty much wherever you want.
If you wanted to do this sort of
learning during pre-training, you could.
If you just want to do it in mid-training or post-training,
you also could.
Right, there's no reason why this has to belong
into the pre-training box,
it's just for the sake of this diagram.
And very crucially, when we're talking about RL
in particular,
there's no reason why we need to limit ourselves
just to code.
Right? Anything where the model can
learn signals from what it's doing, and there's a rich
variety of signals
can be modeled like this.
It doesn't just have to be programming, right, it
could be
translation, it could be anything where there is
a clear structured signal
from which the model can learn.
Now, something that is not strictly within
the realms of model building
is that finding these problems inside a business
can be very difficult. Inside an enterprise can be
very difficult.
We've recently launched a forward deployed research
engineer,
er, essentially function as part of our company
to help you find these problems.
And if these problems exist and we can
integrate them into our model pipeline like
this, you will be able to benefit
from an uplift in model capabilities at that
task.
So if there is a task that is suited to this sort
of setup, if you imagine the code execution box
doesn't exist.
Then that's something where the model can learn
and grow at that particular task.
Now, once we have this,
the only thing
that's on this side of the diagram that we haven't spoken
about yet
is actually adjusting the model
itself. Right, I mentioned earlier that you can choose
when to spend your parameters,
but we haven't really spoken about it so far.
Normally what happens here is you have
some idea that you want to try.
Let's say you want to have more embedding parameters
or more experts active
in your MOE or any of these things.
And it's useful to be able to express these very succinctly.
So in practice, this box here on the left hand
side, the model ablation platform,
is essentially a collection of four loops
inside our internal repository.
You specify all of the parameters that you
want, let's say the number of experts.
And our system automatically takes those
and launches a training run for each of
them. Now normally it's on a
small model, so we wouldn't train a huge model
on this, maybe a few billion parameters.
But normally this is enough to give you a sense
of whether you're in the right direction
if you're going along the right path.
I liken this to having children at school, right,
if the class is bad, chances are you'll
be able to tell they aren't learning very quickly, and
it's the same with this. And you wouldn't waste your time
with that child in that class if it wasn't going well.
So having the system here really helps you
to take your model.
And understand whether it's going to be viable for you.
I think you already have noticed from what's been on the
slide so far that there's a huge amount
of coordination that's needed for this.
If you take away nothing else from this talk,
it has to be this slide,
which is that a great deal of modern AI
model building
is essentially systems work.
It's about making sure that your training
proceeds reliably. It's about making
sure that your chips are performing. It's
making sure that you don't have any networking bugs.
It's about making sure that all of these systems
can talk to each other in a way that doesn't
slow any of them down or doesn't harm the
design of any of them.
Now I say systems here
and not distributed systems,
because actually there's a lot of traditional systems
programming as well,
right, making sure that your kernels are very
quick, making sure that you can read
files without going onto an out of memory error.
There's lots of things here that are not just
distributed systems.
And something as someone who is more of an engineer than
a researcher these days,
I find that doing this work really enables
people who are much smarter than me
to do their best work at poolside.
Right, to actually be able to research and
understand their own ideas more quickly
than they could anywhere else.
It really enables them to not have to think about
the minutia of scheduling jobs
or making sure that their nose don't crash.
The systems that we have built handle
all of that for them.
And so they don't have to worry about that, they don't have to spend
their hours debugging trivial things.
They get to spend their hours thinking about big problems
and coming up with solutions to those problems.
Now I've said that a great deal of modern
model building systems work,
but I want to stress the rest is science.
And when I say science, I mean a very
traditional science.
I mean empiricism. I mean you have a hypothesis,
you test that hypothesis, you see how
it went, and you repeat this process
over and over again until you end up with something
that is good.
I think this is not really understood
by the outside world because the thing that
they see is the outer product,
right, it's the big model release that everyone
makes a lot of noise about, it's the deep seek moment.
It's all of these things that are very, for want
of a better term, hype,
but it doesn't really reflect the hard work that
goes into building these models in practice.
One of the things that any of you who have done
science in any serious way will know
is that your data is everything.
Keeping track of your data and being
able to understand what it is that you have done
to get to where that data is now
is incredibly important.
I mean, even those of you who plotted graphs at school
will know that you had to be aware of outliers,
and AI is no different.
So one of the key pieces of this model factory
that we're discussing today
is having the ability to transform our
data at scale.
Now this can be as simple as
getting rid of non-permissive licenses
from your training data set,
making sure you aren't training on anything illegal,
but it can also be as large as doing deduplication,
right, making sure that the model doesn't see
too much of one particular data and so it doesn't
overfit.
Being able to track all of that and
being able to make sure that you have a very
consistent lineage, like a chain of custody
for everything that you've done along the way,
is a really important way of making
sure that you understand, OK, I fed
this into my model, and this is
what happened.
This is why the loss went down or this
is why the loss went up.
And there's lots of really clever tricks that you can
play to incorporate this whole system
together. So for example, one thing
that you can do
is during your training, if you build
such a thing,
you can uniquely link loss spikes
back to the data sample that caused those loss spikes.
And that information enables you later
to look at your data and go actually, you
know what, that sample was out of distribution, or
actually we really want this in our training data
set, let's try and get more of it.
There's lots of clever tricks you can play when
you have this sort of systems view of
your training.
Now, One of the things
that the AI industry doesn't tell you very often
is that
we all train on
various rephrased forms of web data.
Now everyone tells you that they train on the web, that's
no secret,
but training on
web data as it is just, you know, purely
scraped
often is not what is best for your model.
What is good for your model is to have data that is
expressed in a particular form.
Right? I don't think anyone here in this room has learned anything
difficult by reading, you know, raw text
snippets from the internet.
Chances are you learned from a lecturer or from a
book that you studied yourself
that had already been organized in a way that made
it easy for you to learn things.
And one of the great things is that you
can do this very similarly with
synthetic data generation.
Now to be clear, this requires you to have access
to inference again,
right, because you need to query some
model that does the work for you.
But you can already see how this diagram really
stacks on top of itself, how all
of these boxes are beginning to interact
with each other
in a way that enables them to be more than the
sum of their parts.
Right, inference by itself is very useful,
but when you can use it to generate more data.
Suddenly that means you can make better models,
which also means that they can be more useful
for synthetic data generation.
So the whole thing really builds on itself
when you have a diagram like this.
Another thing that you can see as highlighted on this slide
is this blender box.
Now, historically, when you've trained
a model,
what you have done is you have chosen the number of
nodes you want ahead of time,
you've distributed the data set to those nodes,
and then they have run off and done the training.
This is fine and it kind of works,
but actually there's a lot of limitations to it.
So one of the limitations to it
is that
you have to have your data ready ahead of time,
right? You can't stream data
to these nodes, as the way I've described,
because you have to predistribute your data set.
Equally, it makes it really hard to scale
up your training in any meaningful way.
It's quite easy to scale down because, you know, you just
take some pool of nodes and you shrink them.
But if you want to scale up, you've got to redistribute
your dataset.
That also can be a real pain if you've got to replace
a faulty node,
right? Let's say you've got 8000 GPUs
that are being used and one of them dies.
Well, suddenly you have to add a new machine in and
you have to preload the data set onto that node.
And that's really tough,
right? It makes your training much more difficult than it
needs to be.
So one of the things that we do at Poolside is
we stream data directly into
our training nodes
via this service that we have called Blender.
Now as the name suggests, Blender also
produces data, blends.
So you'll mix multiple different data sources,
you know, Shakespeare, code, all of
these things.
Because it turns out that much like a kid at
school, you don't want to expose your model to
just one thing at once.
Right? If you, if you only read Shakespeare
and then suddenly you learned C programming,
that would probably be quite confusing.
And the same thing is true of models, right, they like
to be taught multiple things at
once, admittedly in a structured way
so that they can keep things in their head
whilst they're learning.
One of the other great things about streaming
data into your training
is that filtering and producing
data is incredibly time consuming
and expensive.
I probably estimate that on any
given day, admittedly when we're not doing
anything else, the vast majority of our GPUs
are used for synthetic data generation at any given
time. If
you had to wait for those to be done,
that streaming process into, oh sorry, that
preloading into training
would set you back by weeks.
You can't afford this if you want to be at the frontier, you've
got to be able to continuously improve.
And so one of the great things that Blender allows
you to do is to stream your data
into your training nodes.
It turns out that this has other advantages
as well,
because you can adjust things on the fly.
Right, if you suddenly decide that you need a new blend
or a new er data mixture or you want
to add another data source,
streaming enables you to do that very easily.
And so all of a sudden you have many advanced
techniques that you can play with when you
come to train your model.
Right, maybe you see your loss curve going up halfway
through and you think
I need to add more Fortran code to this.
OK, that's very easy to do.
If you redistribute everything, that's way, way
harder.
And even things as simple as like tokenizing
your data
or packing your documents into one
big form. Is not
necessarily theoretically very difficult,
but the practicalities of it kind of get quite thorny
quite quickly.
And having a service like this that handles it all
for you,
really enables you to move quickly and have
new ideas that you can actually act on.
Now I mentioned earlier that we do a
great deal of vibe checking at poolside,
and so it's only right that we have this
box right at the end of pre-training and also
post-training.
This, it turns out, is actually very
useful even on partially trained
models. So I mentioned earlier, maybe
your model has got some common failure case, right,
maybe you can interrogate this early.
But actually one of the things that we have found
this enables
is for members of the poolside
GTM team that are in customers,
to give us feedback about what doesn't work.
Oftentimes it's really difficult to get
in-field information
because, you know, there's a huge number of
people that are between any given person.
But when you have an introspection platform like this,
it becomes really easy to drop bad samples
into this, and for people to go, oh hey,
this thing doesn't work very well.
And it really enables everyone at Poolside to be
part of actually building the models.
It's not just the domain of the researchers that
actually, you know, do the nitty gritty hands-on
work. Everyone from our head of HR
to our communications director to
everyone in between,
plays with our models
and uses them to get a good understanding of
what's actually going wrong.
And even, I mean, some people in the company very
recently have picked up vibe coding as well, which has been
quite fun when they haven't had any coding background
before. And that is a really
good testament to how effective this
is. Giving everyone the ability
to actually play and interact with the model
suddenly makes it much more of a community thing
rather than just some people who work on pre-training
thing. Now,
I'm sure you've all
noticed by this point that this box originally
only pointed to the pre-training step.
But it should be clear, right, that actually, you
want to be able to ablate everything.
There's nothing here that shouldn't be subject
to some fixing.
So to be frank about what I mean,
normally what we do is we fix
some particular piece of
the architecture, so let's say the
model architecture or the fine tuning
that we're going to use or whatever,
and then we alter any of these pieces
independently to see what happens.
This in general is just good science hygiene, right,
you try not to move too many variables at once because
you can have confounding effects.
But in terms of model building, it actually
really matters.
And again, this is really a limitation of 2D
space. Every diagram or every
box on this diagram should really talk
to every other box,
right? Our model ablations actually also
happen in code execution.
We don't use every code execution task
for every model.
We don't use every reinforcement learning algorithm
that we've got for every model.
We don't even run the same evaluations
necessarily on every model because they might not be relevant.
And so having the ability to
adjust any piece of this really
easily and quite frankly seamlessly.
Really enables you as a company
to move much faster than you otherwise would be able
to. This diagram
is also horribly incomplete and out of date.
Um, I apologize for
fitting on such a small slide.
There are probably somewhere between 50 and 100
such boxes like this in our model
factory at any given time, and probably
every week we end up with a new one.
This system really ever evolves.
When we first built it, it was much like
the system that I described to you earlier on,
right, it was, we had these 3 boxes, then
we added evaluation, then we added inference.
But actually it continues to evolve as our
needs as a business change, our needs as
a frontier company change.
For example, one of the boxes that was not on this previous
slide was quantization.
So the ability to take your model and shrink down
the size of the weights or the activations
or any of these things.
It turns out that that is also something that you
really want to be able to play around with,
because maybe.
A quantized model
in one place
might be substantially worse than the
original model.
But maybe certain architectures, when you
tweak them, are more, let's
say, resilient
to quantization.
Knowing that is really important
because it means that you can make informed decisions
about the models that you're actually building and training.
And so having some er
capacity or some ability to
accurately look at these things
really matters, and having the ability to adapt
this system
really matters.
Another thing that's really important about the Model factory
is that it serves as a basis of
everything that we do in the company.
Whenever a new joiner joins the company,
normally there's some time that it takes them to get
up to speed.
And invariably there's some moment of,
have you tried this? Have you thought about
that? Having a system like
this enables you to point new
people to the things that you've already done,
or the data sources that you're already using
or the RL algorithms that you've implemented.
All of these things together are important
to get people to be efficient.
And I mean, even me, I've been at the company since
nearly since founding,
and there are things that I think about every day
that people have thought about months ago, and I've just not
asked them yet.
And being able to go and check and go, oh, OK, they
had this idea, great, it worked, or great it
didn't, is really very useful.
It decouples the work from the
workers.
It means that people can have insights
independently.
And actually it's one of the real strengths of this sort
of way of engineering
is that
other than like scheduling constraints or
just team and company missions.
You're able to be much more effective individually
than you would be if you were doing everything in the old fashioned
way, right? I can sit at my computer,
I can launch a training run, assuming I've got enough
compute,
and then I can have an answer very quickly.
And providing there's enough compute in my compute queue
and I don't have to, you know, do something that's more
pressing. I I, we
can have these insights,
and it enables us all to move much faster.
It enables us to be much closer to the frontier
and crucially to continue being at the frontier
as time goes on.
It also acts as a real ultimate source
of truth.
I think AI as an industry is
one that is very full of opinions. I
think if you asked anyone here about their opinions
on Transformers versus linear attention.
AMD versus Nvidia,
which company is going to win,
all of these things are ultimately opinions.
And it turns out that having an ultimate
source of truth of
no we tried that, it didn't work, or
no we tried that, it looks promising,
or even just having the ability to experiment
over a conceptual disagreement.
Really helps you to understand what it is that
you're doing,
and it removes a lot of the noise,
right? I personally don't ever look at Twitter,
I don't ever see what anyone is posting about the models
that they're building,
because I know that if I'm interested and I find an idea,
I can try it,
and if it works,
great, perfect.
This enables you to really decouple
yourself from everything else that is going on
in the outside world,
and it enables you to focus on your mission
and what's happening.
You don't have to think about what anyone else thinks is the
latest and greatest idea,
you yourself can try it.
And having a system like this really, I must
stress, does enable you to experiment with things
very easily.
If there is a new attention variant or
some new post-training algorithm or
QK norms versus layer norms versus RMS
norms or any of these things,
you can adjust just that piece
and leave everything else the same.
And it means that you really don't have to deal with all of
the amount of minutia that you would otherwise have to handle
when it comes to evaluating these ideas and
seeing how they actually work.
Something to point out, I know I've already mentioned this briefly,
is that the factory really grows from
itself. So one of the good examples
is that in our code execution
environment that I mentioned before,
for a long time we had very static
rules, right, this is a C project,
OK, run make or run GCC.
This is a Python project,
OK, run Pip install.
But actually that's very far from how
a human does this,
right? What a human does is they look at the
read me, they look at the installation instructions,
they follow the steps.
If it's a C++ project, it's probably missing some
dependencies, and so you've install those,
and then you get something that works.
It turns out that agents are also really
good at this. And so what
we did was we built an agent that would build
these environments for us, that would build these containers
for us. And when you have that,
that enables you to build better models,
which in turn means you can build better agents.
And you just can see how this process really
builds on itself to keep you moving very
quickly and enabling you to do things
that you couldn't do otherwise.
It means that you are, you can really
benefit from your own good work
almost immediately.
Synthetic data generation, as I mentioned earlier,
is another example, right?
As your models get better,
they're much more capable of rephrasing,
annotating, synthesizing,
which enables you to train better models
later on. This whole thing
really builds on itself and enables you
to compound.
I think as engineers we all know that good abstractions
compound,
right, this is one of those classic things that you're taught as
an undergrad,
but it's also very true in AI.
When you get that architecture right,
or when you have built something that you know, you can
stack on top of itself,
suddenly you see benefits immediately,
both from a model perspective and from a
systems perspective.
Now I've spoken a lot about the theory so
far, but I wanna give you a sense of what
this actually looks like practically and what
this looks like on a day to day basis for someone like
me who works on it.
So one of the key aspects
of all of this is what we term an asset.
Now an asset is essentially a versioned
piece of code and data
in some directed acyclic graph.
And the crucial aspect of any asset
that we have
is that you can regenerate it from
scratch on demand.
Every asset is linked to the exact git
commit of the code that used that
was er was used to produce it.
The exact data sets and the lineage
that were used to produce it.
And what that enables you to do is,
let's say later on you think to yourself,
you know, I had a bug in my data processing pipeline,
or I really just wanna see, you know,
if I do this again, will I get the same result?
Suddenly you have the ultimate ability to reproduce
things. And I want to be clear, even
though you might have the same code and same data,
you might get a different response or a different
result. And this is because obviously
you're dealing with systems, right, chaotic systems.
Maybe your node died,
but died silently, and so that affected
the computation of some activation or something
like that.
Having the ability to reproduce things on
demand really matters.
And crucially, when you have everything structured
in this way.
Running new experiments based on old stuff
is really easy,
because what you can do is you can take the asset
configuration that you had before.
You can fork it, much like you would fork
something on Git.
Make an adjustment and then run it,
and all of the previous lineage,
everything you've done, all of the code that you've had before,
stacks on top of itself.
And suddenly you're able to experiment in new and
very exciting ways that you just couldn't do before.
This is an example of what I mean.
So you can see these, uh, our actual
graph is much, much larger than this, and
this is just an artist's rendition.
But you can see what happens here, right, we have all of these
different boxes
that feed into each other.
Now that vertical stack that's
uh 2 from the right,
you can see is a deduplication stack,
and you can see that each of them end with a different
number. This, it turns out is
the percentage similarity uh parameter
that we used when we were doing deduplication.
And you can see here how all of these boxes
feed into these other boxes.
And enable you to experiment more than you otherwise
could, right? If I wanted to add a
code 0 DU 40 box,
I could also do that,
right? There's no reason why this needs to
be the way that it is. I can play
to my heart's content with these different parameters.
And then when you have these,
you can feed them into the next thing and the next thing
and the next thing, right?
Deduplication doesn't have to be the last thing on your
pipeline, it can be the first or the
last or somewhere in the middle. Maybe
you run it twice, who knows?
There's lots of things that you can do when you have a
system that is structured and built like this.
Another thing that you really need is
the ability to schedule jobs on
your cluster.
So at the moment we have something like 10,000 H200s
that we use. We have more coming soon.
But having all of that compute only means something
if you can effectively utilize it.
And it would be really silly to just say, right, we're
gonna use all of these GPUs for training
all of the time.
Because actually sometimes you, you're just doing
something else, right? You don't want to do a big pre-training
run. You want to do data generation or you wanna
do fine tuning or you want to do reinforcement learning.
And sometimes you don't even need a whole node
for the job that you're doing.
Right, if you have a really small model,
you probably don't need a whole,
you know, 8 H200s to run that. You could
probably run it on just one.
Having the ability to schedule jobs
on machines
in arbitrary ways and ways that actually
grow and shrink depending on the work that you're
doing is really key to
having a system like this.
If you don't have something like this,
you're always gonna have ways to compute. You're
always gonna move more slowly than you otherwise
could. And ultimately you're never
gonna get to the frontier of things,
because someone else will have that advantage.
So having the ability to schedule jobs
essentially arbitrarily.
And crucially, not having to worry about that
as a researcher
really is one of those things that enables you to move
quickly. One of the other good things
about having a really robust scheduler
is that you don't need to worry about failed
nodes. Because every job is
a configuration, right, I mentioned before that
everything was an asset.
So if I detect that a node has failed
during some pre pre-flight check or
during the actual job itself,
I can just switch that node out with another one,
and everything is good,
right? I don't need to worry about having to
do systems configuration myself or setting
up the networking or anything.
It all just works.
It also as a as a system
has a distributed logbook associated
with it. So I mentioned before that
we have this directed acyclic graph,
but actually each of those also link out
to various er metric platforms
as well.
And we collect all number of metrics, right, we
have our traditional training metrics,
but we also record a huge amount about the efficiency
of various jobs,
a number of GPUs that they use, when they were
busy, when they were idle,
their power draw.
Collecting all of those things really enables you
to do a lot of things.
So for one, it enables you to look at
certain workloads and go,
do we need to make this faster?
Or actually, can we scale it down, right, maybe it's
mostly waiting for network most of the time, well,
perhaps we don't need as many GPUs then.
It also crucially enables you to
get more insights about reliability.
One of the things that we've seen is that nodes
tend to fail under certain workloads.
So if you're running, you know, mini matrix multiplications
back to back to back,
chances are that's going to overheat your GPU.
If we detect that that workload is there
and that workload is actually crashing nodes in
practice,
there are more precautions that we can take to
make sure that that doesn't happen.
And again, sometimes you're, you know, you're just unlucky,
sometimes things happen,
but having a log of every single thing that you
did, and every single thing that has happened
and will happen
is a really good way to make sure that you're
not. Missing out on insights
that would enable you to get closer to the frontier.
I want to talk briefly about how all of this feeds
into large scale training runs.
I think large scale training runs are kind of the big headline
number that everyone gets excited about.
Right, when you saw last year that Deep Sek released
a model that was trained on only a few 1000 H200s,
or, or when Mr. Ow yesterday announced that they
trained their large model on only 2000 H200s.
Everyone always talks about the large scale training
runs. And it makes sense, right? It's
the thing that gives you the most eyeballs, it's
the thing that talks about the most money.
It's clear to see why we like this.
But what I want to point out to you is that there's
actually not that much difference between the large
scale training runs
and the small ones when you have a system
like this.
So this diagram that I showed
you before
of the asset flow
is exactly the same
no matter whether the model that you're training is
big or small. All
you do is you tack another box on the end,
you specify more GPUs or a different configuration
in some way,
and that's it.
There's no distinction in our system between
small models, a 7 billion parameter model,
or a 5 trillion parameter model.
You just adjust what it is that you have in
your configuration in some way, perhaps
some way that's determined by research,
and that's it.
And everything I've said to you so far is also
true for those big runs,
right, you can interrogate what's happening with your workflow,
you can see where the network is slow, you can
see, oh hey, actually maybe we need more GPUs
or maybe we can get away with fewer.
All of the insights that I've mentioned so far
also hold for big models as well as
small models.
So you don't have to worry about whether your big
model is training well or whether your loss spikes,
because you'll know if it happens.
You can sleep soundly.
And on a personal note, one of the things
I love about this system
is we all sleep soundly.
Because actually it's really reliable.
In times gone by,
engineers would stay up all night to make sure that
their training didn't crash, or if it did crash, it
would be all hands on deck.
Now we mostly have automated systems that recover
these things for us.
Sometimes, granted, there is a need for manual intervention,
but that is way less common than it is almost
anywhere else. And it's way less common than it used to be
even for us.
Most other companies have whole teams
that are just dedicated for babysitting a
training run. We do not.
And that is a crucial thing about moving quickly,
because let's face it, your headcount is an
expense.
Hiring more engineers in AI is a very expensive
thing. And if you can scale
and compete with people without having to
hire ever more people.
There's a lot more you can do, right? You can have more GPUs
or you can afford to get better people.
Or alternatively, you can enable the
brilliant people that you've hired
just to do the work that they actually care about.
I don't think anyone goes into AI because they want
to wait all night to fix some scheduling
issue, right? They want to build AGI, they want to
solve hard problems.
Having a system like this enables that. It
enables you to get people who
want to move quickly
and to enable them to move quickly.
They don't have to deal with internal politics, they don't have to
deal with systems that are flaky and don't work.
You have this whole system and it just works for them.
And it enables us to move so much faster,
it enables us to punch well above our weight,
and it enables us to stay ever closer to the frontier.
Before I wrap up, I just want to point out that
actually comparatively few GPU
hours are actually spent on the big
training run. It's a real misconception in
the industry.
Everything I've spoken about so far
has been based around.
You know, doing ablations on small models
or playing with different parameter mixtures
or playing with new RL
algorithms or things like that.
This is very much the case,
right, we spend our GPUs on those
things, on making sure that our
model can scale when it does scale,
making sure that the new algorithms that we've trialed
play out on a small scale.
Making sure that our data mixture isn't just horrendously
awful.
Right, we stack all of these things together
at a small scale.
And I promise you, every other foundation
lab in the world that makes models
does the same thing.
The reason why Deepeek were able to produce such
a good model nearly a year ago
was because they had tried many
small optimisations and tweaks
and ideas
and then combined them together to make a model that
was good. And all of those
ideas probably had to be trained in or had to be
tried independently, right? I don't know I wasn't there.
But I can't imagine that you would make all of those tweaks
just on a whim.
Right? Chances are you're at least going to look at it first and
go, oh actually that means something,
that's important.
And it turns out the same is true for us, right,
we spend comparatively few
of our GPU hours on a
huge training run.
It's more the ta da at the end of the year
or during, you know, some point, right, we go, oh,
actually we're ready, let's train a big model.
And then it can, you know, it proceeds for some weeks,
but actually ultimately that's not where we spend most of
our time, that's not where we spend our thinking time.
One of the things about having such a system though is it
gives you the confidence that if tomorrow you
needed to train a new big model, you could.
Right? If someone came down to me
and said, Joe, we need to train a new state
of the art model tomorrow, can you do it?
This system gives me the confidence
to say yes.
I don't have to worry about how we're going to get there because the
system enables you to already have those insights in
place. We have many buns in the oven,
as it were, right, we're constantly iterating over
these things,
and at any given point we know what we need to
do to improve our model.
Having a system like this really enables
you to have such confidence in
what it is that you're doing.
And actually, as someone who works there, that
really matters,
right, knowing that we can keep up
with everyone else, despite having a much smaller
team is perfect, that's what I want.
I want to have that confidence. And having a system
like this gives that to you in spades.
With that being said,
If you're interested in going from
being artisanal to being industrial, we are hiring.
All of our open roles are on our website.
And if you're interested in what I've spoken about, we're at booth
802.
So please feel free to head down and come and say
hello. And with that, I'd like to thank you all for listening.
If you've got any questions, I'd be happy to answer them.